unberührte natur sich selbst überlassen
ohne dass die forstwirtschaft stört
wildnis davon braucht deutschland mehr
so will es die bundesregierung
wir müssen schutzgebiete aus werden wir
müssen ökosystemen renaturieren
mit wir meine ich alle staaten ein
appell an die welt doch was gilt für
deutschland
mecklenburg vorpommern in den wäldern
bei feldberg unterwegs mit förster und
buchautor peter wohlleben gemeinsam mit
dem biologen karibisch inspizierte einen
wald mit alten buchen wirtschaft statt
wildnis also das macht in dem fall
überhaupt keinen sinn alte buchenwälder
gibt es in dieser qualität wie die mal
waren nur noch im promillebereich
holz ist ein toller rohstoff gar keine
frage aber wir nutzen zu viel und wir
verramschen unser ökologisches
tafelsilber und das liegt jetzt hier am
weg klein geschnitten und offensichtlich
marx keiner haben erwachsene mich schon
die pilze der wald hier ein schutzgebiet
ein sogenanntes fauna flora habitat
lebensraum für streng geschützte arten
trotzdem ist forstwirtschaft erlaubt die
folge hier kein geschlossenes kronendach
mehr weil alte bäume gefällt wurden
ja man hat sich eine alte buche
abgeschlagen so was was sieht man hier
wie sie sehen sehen sie nichts außer
eben hier so eine kaputte glas und
dieser boden
man sieht ja dieses dunkle das ist humus
der verband jetzt in der sonne das
gigantische mengen an kohlenstoff aus
kohlendioxid wenn das hier verordnet von
bakterien und pilzen also das hier ist
ein beitrag zum klimawandel aber leider
negativer auf nachfrage attestiert das
umweltministerium von mecklenburg
vorpommern dem schutzgebiet einen
günstigen erhaltungszustand der wald sei
durch das fällen von bäumen nicht
zerstört sondern verjüngt worden
auch die holzstapel seien inzwischen
weitgehend abtransportiert
wohlleben und ibis gehen nur rund
hundert meter weiter in die heiligen
hallen ein totalreservat wildnis hier
ruht die forstwirtschaft seit 150 jahren
die buchen bis zu 300 jahre alt das
kronendach dicht und beschlossen
stürme haben hier nicht so viel schaden
angerichtet wie außerhalb im
forstwirtschaftlich genutzten
schutzgebiet im rahmen unserer forschung
haben wir dann natürlich auch
festgestellt just in diesen extremen
jahren 2018 2019 wie sehr die buchen
außerhalb anfangen zu leiden und
absterben durch die hitze und durch die
trockenheit und da erkennen wir genau
die wirkung die das ausmacht wenn ein
wald sich selbst überlassen wird sich
selbst regulieren kann sich selbst ein
mikroklima schafft eine info tafel zeigt
es innerhalb des schutzgebietes macht
die wildnis der heiligen hallen gerade
mal 66 hektar aus für die waldexperten
zu wenig größer ist deswegen so wichtig
weil ökologische systeme platz brauchen
um sich aus hier ist man einfaches
beispiel sondern pixelige bild katze
braucht schon bis zu zehn
quadratkilometer ein tier und für eine
lebensfähige population brauchen sie 400
tiere
wo sollen wir leben ja und so wird es
ganz ganz vielen arten die brauchen groß
zusammenhängende räume die geben wir
denen nicht das sind eigentlich nur die
krümel übrig bleiben die eu will mehr
als krümel 10% schutzgebiete ohne
wirtschaftliche nutzung die
bundesregierung ist bescheidene bis 2020
sollten zwei prozent des landes zu
wildnis werden
gemeint sind damit laut bundesamt für
naturschutz ausreichend große weitgehend
unzerschnittene nutzungsfreie gebiete
die dazu dienen einen vom menschen
unbeeinflussten ablauf natürlicher
prozesse dauerhaft zu gewährleisten
wildnisgebiete sollen in der regel
mindestens 1000 hektar groß sein
frontal21 fragte bei den bundesländern
nach ergebnis vom ziel 2 prozent wildnis
ist deutschland weit entfernt
bis heute sind es insgesamt gerade bei
0,6 prozent
das größte flächenland bayern wollte
keine angaben machen
also haben wir selbst nachgerechnet mit
den kernzonen der nationalparks
bayerischer wald und berchtesgaden kommt
der freistaat nur auf 0,45 prozent
kürzlich hat das land den schutz für
einige weitere große waldgebiete
beschlossen damit kommt bayern auf 0,63
prozent wildnis zu wenig meinen
naturschützer einen weiteren
nationalpark im steigerwald fordert ralf
straußberger vor allem wegen der
wertvollen wildnis alter buchenwälder
es kommen auch viele leute zu besuch die
sich diese naturwunder anschauen wenn
eben wälder bäume mal alt werden dürfen
200 300 jahre also am baum nicht nur so
dünn sondern richtig mal ein meter
fünfzig solche buchen hat man in
normalen wirtschaftswäldern nicht auch
die grüne opposition in bayern fordert
einen dritten nationalpark doch wie
sieht es dort aus wo die grünen
mitregieren rheinland pfalz hessen und
baden württemberg schneiden bei
wildnisgebieten schlechter ab als bayern
schlusslicht ist mit nordrhein westfalen
das flächenland mit der höchsten
bevölkerungsdichte doch kein einziges
bundesland erreicht das minimalziel von
zwei prozent nicht mal mecklenburg
vorpommern mit seinen großen
nationalparks
viel bessere zahlen meldet schleswig
holstein das land bescheinigt sich 1,9
wildnis zu recht
die hahnheide eines der größten
zusammenhängenden waldgebiete in
schleswig holstein
naturschützer kritisieren dass die
landesregierung schon flächen ab 50
hektar als wildnisgebiete bezeichnet und
so seine statistik schön rechnet mehr
oder weniger abstrus weil der ganze sinn
von wildnisgebieten wird damit ja
verkehrt wildes gebiete sind ja nur dann
wertvoll wenn sie eine gewisse größe
haben damit die dynamiken auch dann
stattfinden können
die 1,9 prozent von schleswig-holstein
schrumpfen auf nur noch 0,49
legt man die gleichen maßstäbe an wie
bei den anderen bundesländern
der grüne umweltminister jan philipp
albrecht bei einer baumpflanzaktion
schriftlich lässt er mitteilen es gebe
in schleswig holstein keine ausreichend
großen waldgebiete für wildnis deshalb
fühlt sich das land nicht an die
mindestgröße von 1000 hektar gebunden
[Musik]
dabei würde das schutzgebiet hahnheide
alle anforderungen an eine wildnis
erfüllen
es ist 1400 hektar groß und gehört der
allgemeinheit doch offenbar sind der
landesregierung die einnahmen aus der
forstwirtschaft wichtiger als die
eigenen ziele in sachen biodiversität
auf anfrage teilt das umweltministerium
mit zitat
die bestehende forstwirtschaftliche
nutzung steht der einstufung der
hahnheide als wildnis entgegen
es gibt ein verfassungsgerichtsurteil
das sagt öffentliche gelder dürfen den
erwerbs wirtschaftlichen charakter nicht
an erster stelle stehen und stellen
sondern müssen immer die erhaltung der
natur und die daseinsvorsorge an erster
stelle stellt das heißt die wissen im
ministerium nicht für die gesetzeslage
ist
wir müssen schutzgebiete ausweisen wir
müssen ökosysteme renaturieren mit wir
meine ich alle staaten fakt ist
deutschland ist an seinen eigenen
ansprüchen bei der umsetzung der
nationalen biodiversitätsstrategie
krachend gescheitert denn im zweifel
gilt wirtschaft statt wildnis